some lovely feel incredibly connected to
a secret thing that is not visible to
anyone else sometimes it's a huge
urgency it's very compulsive and I need
to get you know some kind of thing down
I need to get it out of my head why we
know first we have to work in the world
of darkness and I thought oh gosh that's
that's that's me it sounds like in a way
I was completely an absolutely
devastated it was I was very very very
low and I mean life had just ended and I
and but the one of the things I had been
doing in hospital was you know this is
drawing taking stuff that happens in my
head out there onto paper or into you
know sculpture and things like that and
I think it's a complete act of
dispossession just that's all I've got
left in the way empty the scrap just get
it out of my head get it out there and
you know leave me like just
[Music]
one of the difficulties in understanding
any psychiatric illness let alone
schizophrenia is that you're largely
reliant on the person's subjective
description of their experiences so
Sue's very articulate so you can
actually get all of those experiences
from her and the artwork that she has is
an exquisite way of presenting her
experience of the illness which is
unusually clear in a way she's trying to
understand her illness and try and
express it in a way which is visually
comprehensible and in the same we're
trying to understand the psychotic
experience approaching that from perhaps
a brain imaging or where we're trying to
present pictorially what's happening or
what the dysfunction is in the brain
during that psychotic process so well
for instance this one I mean you can
tell that I'm very distressed and I've
I've started thinking in German that's
devil command and there's a little eggs
when I'm in this particular state then
what I'm experiencing is
Satan has actually laid his his babies
his little eggs in my kidneys I can feel
them no I get so much it you know I can
feel that they're there and then they
get this tickling up the spine because
they're crawling up the spine and
they're going into my head and then
they're these little things are coming
out of my eyes and they're infecting the
entire planet yeah and these are the
little eggs
Jesus so these are the legs what about
these things here legs too as well yeah
and there's the kidney where's that give
me that
what what's going on in my head and I
couldn't see as it were it this is just
a big gap between what I put down on
paper and what's going on it'd be really
nice I could get some sort of snapshot
in the head that's good the snapshot his
idea is quite nice so with using the
kind of fMRI technology we do is we take
patients with schizophrenia who are
prone to hearing voices having auditory
hallucinations we put them inside the
functional MRI machine and we can look
to see what is the brain activity which
is correlated with the experience when
they're having hallucinations against
periods of time when they don't have
hallucinations one of the experiences
that people have is that they hear say
for example voices and I just wondered
whether that was an experience that
you'd also shared yeah what well I get
them but I wouldn't say it's more like
I'm telephone exchange so I can hear
various conversations and there's a
particular set of conversations which
the two people are having a telephone
conversation and I'm intercepting it and
attained start telling they're saying
just I don't even want to repeat what
they're saying but they had very very
boundaries rude revolting just you don't
know let's not go there
so what we can do is actually have a
look at the the brains and this is
essentially just a cut across the brain
starting from the bottom just taking it
from here and just kind of moving slowly
up and then what you can see I guess
here this bit and this bit yeah are the
are the temporal hearing parts of the
brain yeah which seems to be much more
active when people are having the
experience of hearing things so for you
though yeah yeah and then the other
thing you notice is that you've probably
heard of Broca's area which is thought
to be a language generation area so this
is the kind of brain area which is
involved when people are generating
speech like we're doing exactly and so
when people are hearing something here
we're having these auditory
hallucinations what happens is that
there's speech generation parts of their
brain also seem to be much more active
oh so so you're saying that we're
generating in the head I'm saying that
one of the theories that you could look
at will be that is this experience
something that you're generating
yourself and somehow the monitoring of
it you don't have control you don't
realize that that's going on so you may
be sitting there acting as a telephone
conduit and hearing lots of material the
people sitting next you can't tap into
that experience and but yet it's it's
real so one of the thing that's
difficult for people who've never had
that experience is how can it be real if
I sitting next to you can't tap into in
terms of establishing trust with
patients because of this brain imaging
technique would show that the auditory
cortex and subcortical areas are active
when people are hearing voices I can say
to the patient that I now I believe that
you are hearing voices I may not be able
to hear it but I know that you are
because we have this brain imaging data
showing that that's
happens
the easiest way I think force up for
someone on the outside to understand
it's a bit like being in a dream world
except I don't recognize it is a dream
world but that is how I think would most
capture the sense of what's going on
it's like some nightmare
[Music]
[Music]